[Music] At
first, I probably didn't think of it as a Kurazono karuta work, and neither did the director.
It's an unrefined part, and
it happens
to be used in the world of Karuta
, and I think that's why I received it.
In addition, the length of time, whether this person has an intractable disease, etc.,
is put up as a
layout, and based on that layout, it becomes a
language.
[Music]
Crying athletes lose
My cousin is the
people of the world who have been replaced by two people who have lost their clothes and the moment they see it, everything has been replaced by flames
.
It's the same with love, and the elements of working hard
Everything is expressed in that karuta, so if you write karuta in an interesting way, everything will go well
.